you know you've been doing traveling all
over the country and the world doing
press for love Rosie and I'm just
curious I know that I talked to a lot of
actors and actresses that are doing a
lot of press traveling around do you
enjoy that hasn't been going okay
because it's can be quite stressful I
would think yeah it's been we've been
all over kind of Asia and in America
doing press but I I always get a little
bit fumbly with my words when it comes
to doing interview after interview after
interview and recently we were doing an
interview of Sam Claflin and I and they
asked us Nick if you weren't an actor
what would you love to be and I just
rattled out I'd be a master baker right
right because I love baking right but I
didn't realize that it kind of came
across is that a term master baker and
then I was thinking of master chef but I
love baking and so I I put the two words
together became a master baker yeah so
two weeks later who was this interview
for that would be important like not
children's TV I don't remember but two
weeks later Sam sent me a picture of a
bakery called master baker I think we
have that so this actually proves that
you're not inside so that it's so there
is such a thing as master Bobby if you
will notice there's nothing in the
windows the bakery no it's from the
master baker no no one
no one wants very smart yeah no one else
to go in there now you have your fans
are quite interested I'm told in your
eyebrows I mean you you do have your
beautiful you beautiful eyebrows but
they're sort of it's a quality that your
fans they they want to be close to them
they've lost after they asked to touch
them what but I mean you must know what
that's like his people ASSA touch your
hair all the time
right yeah they want to touch it with a
stick they don't know I do find people
are interested in like wouldn't you know
sometimes they see me out in the world
and they want to get their [ __ ] yeah
yeah
what's that can I touch it yes sure
this is a really strange show but wonder
soft that's not real look at that it
goes on with Velcro
you